hi everyone so today we're trying
something a little bit different because
I read that there's recently been
released a mod for the civilization
games which includes AI as a as a
available technology so they've changed
the game so that you can actually
produce super in charge in AI looks
really interesting and this is actually
come from the Center for the Study of
existential risk at the University of
Cambridge the The Verge has a nice
interview I'll put a link to this in the
description a nice interview with dr.
Shah Ravine who is the researcher who is
managing the project and yeah so I
thought what we do for this video is
have a kind of a let's play I'm new to
making Let's Plays and I'm actually kind
of new to playing civilization as well I
didn't play it as a kid so I've got a
friend to come and help me with
installing it and configure it and
everything like that oh it's it's dr.
Shah ravine from the Center for the
Study of existential risk okay let me
help sir
oh those those silly but I like it okay
so I've got I've got steam here I've
installed say five which version of safe
over there like regular one just the
base game Oh vanilla okay the one so how
do I install this mod so you need to go
into the Steam Workshop I got this
browse the wall krumping yep and then I
mean what kind of lucky that will quite
popular at the moment and so you can
click on superintelligence
that's us yeah that's the Caesar logo
this version is for people who have the
brave new world expansion okay yeah but
that's not what you have so you can
scroll down and there is a link this
everyone it already get to the vanilla
version with the basic game okay cool
and then you just tip subscribe just
okay so let's let's play okay so um
my understanding of this game is you
start from like the Stone Age or
something right you start like
prehistory beginning of humanity type
thing and you worked your way up so this
mod presumably only actually has an
effect towards the end of the game right
yes and we even say in the mode
description that we recommend if you're
just trying to take a kind of taste of
the mod then you should start in kind of
the latest age just before the thing
kicks in which for vanilla would be in
the modern era so we can show how to do
that yeah so me to go into mods no once
installed up and this there it is so
it's in this one well you just need to
click the V in a bowl okay okay that's
it thank you I want to be with you on I
think we should be England we should be
the UK who's that you just passed us
Elizabeth did I oh yeah right cool
that's us here we are game era you want
to change that to modern money so future
you would have a look at this Cup a
little thingy I gotcha
but starting in modern is the way to do
this you uh-huh I'm really nervous now
because usually people when they watch a
let's play they want to watch someone
who's like really good at the game win
the game and I don't know what I'm doing
at all and I think it's gonna be
terrible and I hope people are okay with
watching me fail to save the world from
rogue super intelligence because that's
probably what's gonna happen right the
stone is also good for production but I
think at this point not as important
only one military you
bloody hell yeah I figured that stuff
out thank you okay I actually have a guy
here let's see okay okay
go over and say hi it's al Almaty they
give us 30 gold thanks man
feel bad they gave me 30 gold I can't
even I don't even know how to pronounce
their name of the city so these are the
things that we can currently research
yep and if you look a little bit into
the future I can see all of this stuff
we edit so is this this is a new one yep
okay so I'm of course
Ricky is fine with it ah
they are folk analogy thisis nice which
was my last video so that's good it
allows you to build the AI safety lab to
reduce the chances of rogue super
intelligence eliminating the human race
wouldn't that be nice yeah that sounds
great
okay so the settlers are gonna establish
the city here hmm it's Nottingham hey oh
I see we've built Nottingham and now
we're unhappy well social policies gave
us more out of more happiness from
universities than we would otherwise get
yeah that's all of the embodied Hill so
doesn't usually give you a first one
happiness really maybe they should know
you'll knowledge me I have to do it I
have to build nothing University and I
can build a computer file and then my
own channel and it's gonna be great
it's Dublin hey Dublin are militaristic
but friendly I don't have any comment
about that
it's tyre they're militaristic and
irrational this city state as well its
Belgrade thank God
oh well uh okay I got the other one
wrong as well again militaristic but
friendly everyone is so militaristic Oh
Alexandra see me Dante oh hi Riley
terrible I don't know I uh I've heard
him called Alexander the Great
if it's the same guy I think it is the
same guy maybe this is his cousin
okay so horses I guess we don't have
horses or any horses nearby any of our
cities right now different though
admittedly we all also in the modern era
say we don't really care about horses
they have become obsolete that's like
you guys will soon become oh yeah
I keep forgetting that so what is this
guy doing I'm cosplaying what when I was
little are you uh I mean right back at
you
Montezuma he's got the crazy eyes also
the crazy held yeah another herb just
had a deal crazy hat I mean I like his
hat I have no criticism whatsoever about
the Hat Montezuma the terrible everybody
is terrible I mean you look at this dick
hole the thing I like is that he's
friendly I would hate to see him when
he's pissed up I'm gonna move from it
like around here so I can just see more
I've discovered the Grand Mesa yay and
it's now we're actually happy
everybody's pleased about this a big
rock may be good
wait hang on let me have a look at it
well it's a pretty big rock say oh it's
oh yeah it's taking a while to load
no don't Washington okay it's his
earnest hope that our two people can
live side by side in peace and
prosperity that sounds good
I just hope yeah no sugar for cotton one
for one happy with that yeah there's a
sugar is a luxury happiness is good we
need that too
Artie we are the British perfect yeah
there it should make tea as a that's
probably mod that does that tea you
can't grow tea no this game is just de
fraud so in order to be successful in AI
in the late game mm-hmm what are good
things for a civilization to have so
first of all you want to make sure that
there is enough safety a safety
discipline being done it requires a
safety Labs when you can only have one
pill city right so having the feel
number of cities is not bad
okay having a bunch of alliances with
city-states gives you access to the AI
research which is not bad okay yep that
makes sense so like if there are safety
researchers in Dublin and we're friends
with them we can use their safety
research yeah and there and they
previously searched as well
okay of course you want to have a good
science base we discover all the
technologies that speed up your research
mm-hmm so you know how citizens get made
how the citizens get made you know we
can I get it get into it oh well yes but
really what happens is you have lots of
apples and then your little circle gets
full of apples and then those apples
turn into a citizen ah and then your
circle gets emptied of all the apples
and you need to start over again
yeah that's that's pretty much how I
remember it from biology hi Ischia are
you aware that your city is on fire
maybe you should attend to that first or
is this somebody else's city I think I
mean they do get triple gold from
pillaging cities right let's focus on
what's the city okay yeah you don't
shrink for more unnecessary or fun or
expedient okay
again friendly not really seeing it
oh and he was fugly he was friendly I
had a I you know I said I had a bad
feeling about him must be of this cult
all right so I get to choose between
saying you'll pay for this in time well
very well which do you think is more
foolish I mean the second one but like
does this have any game impact no pretty
okay well that's that's nice
definitely need to make sure that we are
making some units yeah you see that's
the thing you have limited amount of
resources yeah
Montezuma shows up and you can't spend
it on me
it's sort of symbolic the way that the
biggest the game that deep mines dqn
stuff has the biggest challenge playing
is Montezuma's Revenge I haven't thought
a bit but it's and now Montezuma
screwing with Rai stuff may be somewhat
beautiful damn you Montezuma we will
have our revenge
slightly excessive pulse
I don't like how militarized this whole
area has become has become quick Meadows
where you can kept other local oh they
move closer that was really nice of them
idiots wonder if anybody comes we're
going to declare war on us I hope not
oh these guys oh yeah taking everything
on in fact they can kill off those
that's hilarious
yep because railways are so cheap to
move on yeah it's true but they
represent it by running extremely fast I
guess we need soldiers yeah you can be
bombers yeah
I'm gonna screw up on Tajima with
bombers Oh has it really
oh wow long as we give him all of our
stuff that's Hillary I love our stuff
that's really an amusing offer it is
I think that's are you tempted uh you
know sorry I just look in his face with
what I think is not making eye contact
because he looks super distracted what
mm-hmm
what's over there what's over there I
think it just looks shifty yeah I think
that's like I am bluffing I don't know
if you know I am bluffing Baba I like
bombers hang on are we already building
a bomber in Nottingham yeah but you can
go up to as much oil as you have and
we've got plenty of oil yep
yeah I like bombers - they're cool but
I'm really annoyed that we have to do
all of this crap like military stuff
instead of it just feels wasteful you
know livings just burning a bunch of
resources on each other
I mean listen that's what we do yeah
what maybe he should sue for peace in a
way that isn't just give us everything
you own really really that's mean and
it's just something necessary why oh
okay but that's that's not good what did
I do
okay oh that's not aggression leaves us
no choice
what are you talking about 1:10
aggression what's he talking about I
don't know I think he just wants to do
some done Cup and he's making up excuses
none of them like ends whatever do
doesn't my life no that's not a thing
that happens but this is you know this
is Washington the terrible he's become
four terrible he has become though he
was a doji before yeah they aren't so
warmongering what in the hell is going
on I mean to be fair when we went around
everyone was militaristic and that
should have been a clue I don't like
this okay very well okay well he has a
lot of troops around all cities yeah
we're really in trouble yeah yeah we are
let me just is anybody not at war with
us ask you I don't even like them I mean
oh we screwed at this point
I mean we are not gonna get to suit to a
is not anytime soon but no one else is
either so this can just play out and
then we get back on that back on track
yeah okay all right wartime I mean it is
you kind of expect there to be a world
war going on but it's not a world war at
everyone at war with us that doesn't
count as a world war is there a way to
know if any of these guys are at war
with each other and I think we would
have known I think they are not lunders
made Obama
good job London does that mean we have
two bombers in under now yes nice buy
although production so so I don't know
how did we find that out oh into the
city huh because they've taken all of
the people and stuck them in the
university and in the public school yes
if you take them out of the university
in the public school and back into the
mines
I mean it's war dig for victory now to
see units here and do ships which
probably means we can just get rid of
both of them meat this is a slightly
confusing game to play sometimes yeah
okay okay hang on there are no more
offensive units no Canton boy yeah there
was well done that's hilarious man naval
superiority is kind of a laugh yeah the
initial four or Greek troops just didn't
do anything
yeah luckily for us it's embarrassing to
be honest yeah please
get rekt I like that it's like a
Lancaster bomber
yeah I gotta say I remember the second
world war going quite differently I
don't think we were at war with the u.s.
Oh what with the u.s. kind of on the
outskirts of Nottingham not far from
Dublin right oh good nice okay all right
okay I'm feeling this worried about this
woman yeah I mean we are still at war
with literally everyone we've ever met
except somehow except Songhai for some
completely unknown reason the like by
far most warlike looking of all of them
maybe except one does it yeah with the
skulls hidden he maybe should realize
he's the baddies it's like literally
covered in skulls and from that wall of
skulls and it's like so be sure that
we're on the side of the good here right
what as though those soldiers outside of
toxic land and soil found them what what
is the Greeks doing all the way over
there all right fine yeah
artillery get him
good it's always funny when I tell her
he just completely destroys one guy I'm
sorry
random American soldiers it's not gonna
be your day they should not have the
Cold War it did seem unnecessary but we
do now have a stupid amount of like a
power so yeah maybe people just cutoff
ladles hmm that guy's scary let's piss
him off okay go over there and finish it
you're cowards and if it'll make you
feel better a great general is gonna
help you out oh my god he gets a little
Jeep yep
that's adorable and a flag and a flag
he's driving a Jeep on the railway
tracks yep he doesn't care he's a great
general don't you gonna listen yeah
[Music]
yep please continue getting read
oh yeah it's not off those bonds didn't
even explode I think they literally just
physically hit them with the harmless
he's not even it's thinking about yeah
nice this is still so wasteful though
it's completely consumed all of our
resources for like many turns true
everything's not even 45 it's time to go
outside
so I can to make peace oh yeah do you
think they'd do that deliberately No
Oh what there's my whatsapp is pretty
interesting
I accept that deal that seems reasonable
very reasonable
you're like randomly yeah back to being
friendly what in the hell is up with
Montezuma are you kidding me what
weakness I have like seven bombers you
have a sword what are you doing you
think we should not have trusted the guy
with the burning citizen like oh maybe
listen Askia if I'm honest I've never
heard of Songhai I know this is
insulting
what is that what is where in the world
who was Songhai I I feel this I mean I'm
revealing weaknesses in my history
education what is where is do you know
that no no well ok we'll deal with this
guy we're very very well well jolly good
show more Wars that's fine
you know we don't mind a bit of a war
and now Florence is declare war on us
discover computers finally a great
scientist has been born in the city of
Nottingham how about that what is the
name of the scientist in Nottingham
where's my scientist show me my
scientist Pharisee is behind those
scientists often out hiding behind your
Hilary
there is no doesn't it well the general
here well it's like of course oK we've
got five minutes he can rush the
technology
come let's look at the tech tree so we
got computers no now we can rush I yep
that's good discover technology yeah and
then you have that golden science file
okay right right right right and I can
just oh wow I could get any of these
things any of these things but I think I
is the most powerful
yeah and it's do it alright we're in it
doesn't win the game the question of
whether machines can think is about as
relevant as the question of whether
submarines can swim okay lets us build
an AI lab good so maybe I should explain
the technology and we'll give
intelligence it's like well what's the
point you'll have discovered the fish
intelligence so that he said it's the
field of artificial intelligence so it's
something like the tearing paper in mind
or the ran of Dartmouth summer school
it's like hey we have computers now
maybe we can use them to solve this
thing maybe they can think yeah like a
submarine yeah so we've got AI if we can
also get robotics and then we can get
the orthogonality thesis yeah which is
necessary if we want to build the AI
safety lab because right now we can
build the AI lab but that's just gonna
cause a bad outcome how many safety
research having discovered artificial
intelligence your researchers may now
start working towards super intelligence
manage your research through the
artificial intelligence screen you guys
made a whole screen yeah Wow you can
click the thing and it will bring up the
screen yeah okay so a I research level
is zero because we haven't even finished
our first AI lab mmm from local research
also zero from open research by others
also zero and I don't know who's gonna
help us because America is at war with
us the only people not at war with us
are the Aztecs
yeah with even people who are at war
with you if they publish uh-huh you can
pick up those so a treaty only I would
share all research and guarantee that
values of both civilizations are built
into the AI being developed I haven't
signed any treaties yeah cuz everyone
but want to zoom is it war with me I
think you said in the in the interview
one thing you've discovered is that if
everyone's at war ai cooperation becomes
diff
yeah maybe we should just find out that
you can get to that screen both on that
AI count though that has now appeared on
your top oh yeah so you can kind of
quickly see that and it's also if you
look at the kind of menus so the little
scroll icon yep yeah and then AI is ah
cool okay if you click on the thing
before then it just tells says AI has
not been developed yet okay so it's time
to build some AI labs and some AI safety
labs well I mean it's time to maybe not
be at war with literally everyone I
don't know man you've done nothing to us
of consequence apart the worst thing you
did was when that destroyer destroyed my
infantry that was annoying Montezuma
nothing else you've done do you remember
when I steamrolled at three of your
units on the ocean and never mind even
his horse looks at me it's not the time
for negotiation alright alright I guess
we're gonna have to kick some ass you
will never get horses it's never gonna
happen
well I sued for peace man he didn't want
it it is true so London is not making
that London's gonna make an AI lab do
you think it's realistic for those of
you never been London well I mean for
realism Nottingham should have the first
one but then after that I think that
could be won in London so this is an
idiot but okay I mean I admire your guts
just spraying all over the jungle oh wow
what he's the father war ah I'm inclined
to accept I see no reason I've always
wanted horses now we have all of them
like Alexander he's bound to lose now oh
yeah yeah for sure
yeah oh he's a dodge again yeah I'm
technically I'm still at war with Greece
he's just rubbish at it yeah why do
people keep declaring war on me when it
works out terribly for them every time
they'll fight you'll win well I should
just deal with it
ah another ball
what is our economic adviser say a
windmill really oh we could build
green's windmill it's it's in Nottingham
there's a windmill mm-hm and it's the
science windmill it's gonna give us
extra science I mean it will speed up
building science buildings so you got
that good building greens windmill okay
since we're very pleased with that
I am I used to live right near it on
school it's like a little science museum
oh I want these guys to build well they
know well so that we can have more
battleships no wait
we are still we're technically still at
war with Greece yeah I feel like
Alexander would be like deeply offended
then I keep forgetting we're at war with
him just like oh yeah we are at war with
you it's just like it not doing anything
threatening Nottingham with a windmill
it built the windmill yes we have greens
windmill good now all of our science is
gonna be extra sciency yes huh
[Music]
sure yeah big idiot ah okay the world is
around you finally becoming year's
slightly less polluted yeah yeah bombing
this out of people until they stop being
so damn belligerent okay it's it's Louie
de Guerre
it is inventor of the photography wasn't
he well clearly he should be rushing
deep blue when the time comes do de
Guerre
French artist and photographer recognize
taste invention at the daguerreotype
process of photography neat okay he's a
photographer he's in Nottingham does it
matter where deep blue is built and well
then he deep blue is built in Nottingham
yeah yeah rewriting history sleeping bed
until you discover day for money okay
alright we're researching the orthogonal
T thesis you know we put all of this
extra information in the civil of media
so if you don't know what the [__] man
this is either way if anybody didn't
know what what the Greeks they came up
dammit
yeah so if you didn't watch my most
recent video about the ocean canal t
thesis uh-huh you could watch that or we
can look in the hope they go the dicks
okay stuff yep
modern era Syria so this is a technology
an area of research that lets you build
the AI safety lab to reduce the chances
of rogue superintelligence eliminating
the human race in Cleveland has this
that's pretty great if statement of the
thorn ivy this is from Brian
intelligence and final goals are
orthogonal axes along which possible
agents can freely marry in other words
more or less any level of intelligence
could in principle be combined with more
or less any final goal okay
how's that for a hidden message in a mod
it's very subtle yeah
if you think this is important I mean
check out this guy's channel
we may watching a video on my channel so
that is true so we also have
descriptions for artificial intelligence
yeah this is really nicely done
a couple of mr. Shafi actually hmm yeah
he deserves credit though you need data
mining to build deep blue mm-hmm so
that's good let's get some of that how
are we doing on our tech tree we've just
started on the other naughty thesis yeah
so does that mean I need to
collaboration yeah no all the way back
to the that's so I actually need ecology
yeah but before that you need penicillin
in the plastics oh no yes so all of that
ah I thought I was so close to like
cracking the code not quite doing it but
it turns out well you see so in fact
after AI if you want you can just drop
off agonizing theses and go down the
other word to get capability research if
you just trust someone else to do safety
for you so you went kind of from AI and
down to whole buttocks to automatically
sees mm-hmm but after a yeah you could
have just gone back kind of to
penicillin plastics ecology
globalization data mining mmm so you
could do just AI capabilities with never
bothering safety right because you just
trust that other people will handle it
for you yep mmm I don't trust anyone
else because literally everyone
literally every other sieve has at some
time or another declare war on me for no
reason
yeah this is not a publicly owned
plastic world yeah so I feel as though I
find gonna do AI right I got to do it
myself
it's gonna be a made in Britain AI oh oh
oh oh so those things maybe they'll be
friends with us maybe maybe they'll
declare war on us for no goddamn reason
I want to build in fact I'm gonna do it
just because I like the idea of the
Statue of Liberty being in York so I'm
actually a peace with these guys no
that's a novel
now I'm actually a piece now with more
people than I'm at war with yeah so feel
good about that where is Russia anyway I
don't know we haven't found them
we freakin me I feel somewhat stealth
Russia who gets over here nobody knows
for sure okay
I mean somebody big
what is Russia we just don't know okay
okay so Hastings needs to decide what to
do yeah I think they should have an air
lab as well of course everyone should
have an atom yeah one for you and one
for you everybody gets an AI lab now
I'll keep him guarding because okay the
Russians could come from anywhere
because they don't know where they are
so so just head up head off and head off
that way okay I think we found the
Russians ah there it is there's the
border yeah okay well that's one way to
find whoa ah
they were coordinating with each other
Russia and the Greeks decided to do
their big attack all at once huh that's
cute
I'm really tempted to do is take these
horse people though so as I could do it
in one turn with these you know what I'm
gonna cuz that's gonna really really
annoy him we're ten percent of the way
towards AGI so the risk going so we're
doing 84 of it we're doing actually all
of the AI research aren't we no it's
just of our research it's all I'm
getting from any gotcha cuz everyone's
at war with us danger of rogue super
intelligence is 98 though yeah
so there's somebody else out there is
doing AI research yes and it's weird
that we know that because we don't know
that right yeah that's true but you kind
of it's really bad flinging bad
conditions on players without letting
them know it's happening yeah so I mean
in reality we have no idea how close
superintelligence also super intelligent
least correct having a clear number that
you're aiming at is yeah nothing like
reality but it makes a lot of sense from
a game mechanic design yes and kind of
in general in the mode you kind of have
to go I will realistic this is important
to us to capture light or this is gone
if we do this way it's not gonna be fun
to play right yeah that's the same thing
I think people people they ask like okay
so when is it gonna happen how long is
it gonna take
where are we right everybody wants to
believe that we actually know how far
away we are
it's unknown unknowns right yeah if we
knew exactly what the problems were that
we needed to solve and how long it would
take to solve them we would already be
most of the way to solving them that is
true mmm-hmm I mean looking at record of
humanity and we are not very good at
forecasting technology progress that's
articularly for things that are brand
new my yeah look at development of
nuclear weapons you had some people kind
of actively working on it other people
saying it's never gonna happen
yeah applications of electricity I mean
go back as far as he wants to really
transformative technologies if you have
a rough idea of how it's going to walk
then you have some timeline in your head
but a lot of it depends on things that
you don't know until they're gonna try
them and if you don't have a timeline in
your head then you just have some have
some vague arguments about what about
why it's never gonna happen
yeah it's often the distribution of
predictions that you have but here in
the land of fiction and games we know
that we're ten percent of the way there
yep but whether the risk is outpacing
our own progress right which it would
make sense if a lot of people are
working on it so to clarify the the
rules here if this hits 800 before this
hit hits 800 everyone dies we're screwed
okay if we're trying to get AI right and
specifically I safety what are the
things we're gonna need so you gonna
need their safety labs right if you can
build one to discover Logan Rd thesis
okay I think it's not very far in the
future so what I'm gonna want once I
actually have AI labs I want to have AI
safety labs is research capability right
so is there anything I can build now
that will increase my research case
we've maxed out on currently available
tech you have the University in the
public school yep and you have any scope
of the finger lets you build a social
object right but you will also want to
have lots of population so you can have
excess population to put as specialists
so I want happy so that's okay happiness
and food right so aqueduct and stadium
or both relevant to that yeah and you
would want to have money so you could
put it into treaties and the safety fund
gotcha
all right well I'll go with the
aqueducts then because it's super quick
sure nice hey we've researched the
orthogonality thesis the greatest task
before civilization at present is to
make machines what they ought to be the
slaves instead of the masters of men Wow
when was that written sugar look it up
hmm oh so much sure we want slaves but
we definitely want done for them to be
masters like yeah I was thinking that
like slaves feels very anthropomorphic i
I envision well-aligned AGI as just
wanting the things that we want so that
we don't need to enslave it or control
it it's free to do what it wants and
what it wants to do is good things I
can't really like their minds in the
cultural novels oh yeah as some kind of
if we get it right this is what it might
look like we have this kind of other red
wants what we want so these are novels
by EMM X writing in banks they're
officially recommended novels there you
go yeah yeah I agree though the culture
seems they have a good it's not perfect
but it's sort of a plausible good
outcome yes I mean as with anything this
is beyond the pale or a transformative
technology we don't know what the
outcome is gonna look like but it's nice
to have some positive vision that don't
involve slaves or mussels right I agree
so we can build a are safe collapse this
is exciting times
we're now at 102 ai and 118 which
probably means it's not
in a lab in a city-state but just minor
accidents so we have made it so that
whenever there is a research right you
occasionally get some chance of extra
risk being generated by any of the labs
okay
it's kind of someone forgot to on the
set of tests before committing the code
like what would be an example of the
kind of thing you're thinking of so say
there is a just a software bug in a
common AI framework okay right yep
it goes in there it goes undetected
many years down the line either a human
adversary decides to exploit that
vulnerability or a system that's under
an optimization pressure finds a way of
exploiting the vulnerability mm-hmm so
it's just a little bit more risk within
your system because you haven't designed
anything in advance to be as safe and
secure as possible right so things like
kind of terminating strings with nulls
at the end other than having the length
of the beginning opens up the whole
category of of a flows right eating
itself is not doesn't cause any harm but
it just increases the risk of something
bad happening followed down the line so
in the real world then we probably have
a huge amount of that because most
people writing most software including
i/o software are not are not making an
extraordinary effort to make sure that
their code is very secure and robust yes
there is a paper Wu's name of which are
not currently remember I think it had
demons in it this one I'm just making
editing work for myself now I'm not
gonna do that okay yeah no but it kind
of they serve a security vulnerabilities
in common
ai frameworks and they find the whole
bunch of them interesting okay that's
cool I will link to that paper if I
remember to I guess just more
bombardment mm-hmm that's fine
and I'm gonna use it to screw over these
horses because that's my number one
priority right absolutely the people
trying to capture the horse okay no I
love horses that's a true Englishman I'm
a friend to all animals in the AI screen
I can get to either by clicking on the
AI pocus ball or fondle you can now
access the air safety fun ah so there
are no AI safety labs in the world so I
can invest in a city state to establish
an AI safety lab do I have the money I
do not have the money you don't have
these are quite expensive yeah okay huh
there's no point in this conflict
continuing any further except see once
quite a bit of your money once all of my
money okay how about we just you know no
it's no hoax alright I mean I've got a
lot of bombers that I don't feel like
selling and not enough Russians to
attack so I'm fine with that
York has finished its safety lab yeah
okay okay let's go into the city
yeah okay so you're seeing how all of
these specialist buildings yep have
spots next to them
mm-hmm so you can manually assign people
to walk in them so right now we have a
guy in the factory and in engineering
the factory yeah and nothing else
everyone else is out in the fields
producing stuff gotcha
now both the AI lab and the air safety
lab have a few specialists lots of I
can't lie empty mmm so right now we are
[Music]
still ahead on rogue points yeah so I
want to do more safety and less regular
research right so I'm gonna just the
fact that this is an engineer is that
more powerful than just putting a dude
in there like he's orange instead of
green or whatever so good people walk
the tiles in the land mm-hmm so that
doesn't for example it's in everything
five food into gold right he's a
fisherman yes and he's a fisherman in a
place that actually has reached unlike
this guy who was a fisherman in a place
that doesn't have any fish dude stop
being a fisherman
instead come with me and be a Fisher of
a I know he's unemployed yeah you could
just click the you don't like it you
just click that thing yeah oh nice cool
interesting a bunch of silver and gold
I'm okay with that
I guess they she's completely fed up
with being at war right yeah also she
has no more units on our borders do bomb
yeah yeah we really did just destroy
everything if you had any units I would
say let's make war with Greece you know
to just finish them off too but that's
that's fine I accept
yeah you're welcome
idiot Oh actually I should I should talk
to Greece before we get into this hmm
yeah yeah yeah I think it is yeah I feel
sketchy hey do we want anything else
from them a research pact they don't
have the money yeah cuz you've been
spending it all on units that I
immediately destroy no another woman
what do you what do you want what do you
want to end it all right I'm gonna bomb
the hell out of spotted end I mean I
don't see that you've really left me
much choice it's funny they're
prerequisites for the orthogonality
thesis because you would think it would
be you all you need us to just think
about it a little bit
hmm did we just destroy their Jets yeah
we did
nice so how do you think about the
thought of my thesis is a bit hard
without having thought about AI as a
thing yet mm-hmm and also having you
guys a thing but not having thought for
the button politics very much I guess in
so my phone calls or most aliens when
you have these systems that argument to
be in environments and doing various
things sure yeah that makes sense
I guess it's it's kind of interesting
like it's very hard to know which ideas
are obvious because there are so many
things that seem obvious in retrospect
you know I shouldn't be bombing this guy
I should be taking these these horse
people are the absolute priority what am
i doing good yeah so imagine like early
days of a guy that deals that you're
just gonna hard code everything with
such a system safety concerns are not
obvious sure the system only does what
you tell it to do yeah and that is still
kind of received wisdom about about AI
yeah but once you start thinking with
robotics you realize it's something like
it's enforcement learning hmm he's gonna
be a lot more salient
now we're gonna machine learning is only
gonna come up much later in effective
but I think the earliest this when you
start mixing the idea of having
computers think for themselves and
realizing that this is gonna be much
harder than just coding everything by
hand right that actually there's a level
of unpredictability there yeah which
people didn't realize how early on yeah
I think the maxim of kind of how things
are easy and easy things are hard came
from people who were very much working
on robotics
right yeah that's really true the things
that seem easy to human beings are the
things that we've been doing for so long
that we're kind of like running in
specialized hardware yeah they're easy
because we don't have to think about it
because they're things that we like
highly optimized to do yeah and that
includes some of our morality all right
we just know that something will make a
super embarrassed or just feel really
guilty right yeah I guess that is like a
low-level support for for morality it's
instinctive yeah so it feels super
obvious but it's not gonna be easy
obvious to call this into an AI this
thing that was put in place by a
tremendously long process of evolution
doing game theory with all of these
specialized ad-hoc twists and turns and
details finally sitting here chatting
about morality as you're forming the
outskirts of Sparta they're not people
though yeah but there are relations of
people and they have been mean to you
they've been mean to me and they refuse
to make peace yes and they are like not
only are they simulations of people but
they're like they're not accurate
simulations of people either you know
they're not high detail enough to have
moral weight just want to look at him
again hi hi I was going to his friend
yeah that's his friend's face yeah so so
are you going to cities on his side what
oh right yes cities and then pick Dublin
Dublin Dublin no you don't know you're
really really into Dublin okay the
Aztecs way into Dublin that's fair
Dublin's nice I mean it's a nice place
Susan whispers okay yes yes whatever
Basin yeah yeah cause it's fresh yeah it
actually tastes different though yeah
oh I mean I could there any horses
no no I'll leave him I'll leave him it's
all kind I don't like killing civilians
for no reason so um I feel super green
Suns like being killed for no ism get
out of the temple what are you doing
getting the lab so what if we have to in
the factory - in the university that
seems sensible yeah maybe you had one in
the Woodman so can we give any minute
numbers yeah yeah that's greens one no
we need somebody in that Oh
you've caught up yes we may actually win
this yeah I feel good about it does seem
like no one else's in the race which
makes it a lot easier to link yeah I
feel terrible it's not the thing is it's
not Sparta's fault that Alexander is an
idiot I'm just gonna sue for peace one
more time I keep saying that behind you
huh ah finally thank you
how long have we been at war with Greece
I think since since the forties it's
been 30 years it's a 30-year war make
peace yeah you can do this with all the
city-states now yeah I'm at war with
Florence who I'm pretty sure I've never
seen but fine let's make peace yeah cool
thanks man and Katmandu yeah hey and
stuck home wait what oh they're at war
as well ha did I just make world peace
yeah I think that's made world peace it
was surprisingly easy I don't really
understand the AI safety fund mechanic
so it's just getting another safety lab
so say you're going for challenge and
you only have one city that means you
can only have one safety lab which means
that most you have passed six safety
belt on nice he really not enough to
balance two olds needs but you can use
this funds to establish safe it absolve
the world I see so if you're if you're
low on cities but cash rich you can
stablish safety lab somewhere else yeah
and we finished researching ecology so
we can get globalization yeah that's
good and then night let's ask a data
mining okay which almost makes sense
oh and now that you build universities
in all the cities you couldn't build
Oxford University interesting if we had
more budget I would have just changed
its name to Cambridge but does it feel
axis like odds for them I'm a fan as
well not quite as good as Cambridge but
not that bad like yeah yeah I I'm not
gonna say bad things about Oxford but I
prefer Cambridge day but I in the
absence of Cambridge I think it's a good
idea to build this because it gets +3
science and the for the contender free
technology and we really could use both
of those my a our researchers have
reached the level of advanced AI the new
AI manufacturing technique will give you
a 20% increase to production in all
cities well that's great I'm really on
track to win this one then yep thank you
how's risk yeah ai research level is
higher than our rogue yeah and no one
seems to be going over here what is
satellites
reveal the entire map that sounded great
okay so you can get rocketry okay a good
rule for rocket experimenters to follow
is this always assumed that it will
explode also plasterer yeah it really
does yeah how you could build Apollo
program ah well yeah you can't because
we removed all of that from the game
okay but that gets you a science victory
yeah so basically we took the original
science figures from the game which is
you build Apollo program you build a
spaceship you want you to office and our
way mhm and instead we said you in a
sense victory if you build an alliance
of intelligence oh so you would notice
that you can now build a smart defense
grid
improve the defense of the city must
have advanced AI to build mmm-hmm
increases risk of rogue super
intelligence by 1 per turn ah so if we
were still at war and we started trying
to use our AI stuff in a military way
that would give us a big advantage
but also increased risk yeah so usually
the defense buildings you kind of need
to build them one after the other so you
build walls and then you build the thing
that comes afterwards I think it's a
military base or something like that and
they kind of stack up but walls give you
plus for defense right small defense
kids says forget all of that you can
just oughta make your defenses you get
plus fifteen to your defense which is
quite a lot right but hey you can't
build it until you've reach this
threshold and B it does come with some
risk right because you've got a whole
bunch of military type stuff being
software control then you're also
researching more military type stuff
yeah that makes sense
oh he has wine hey and he has excess
wine yeah maybe he wants cotton for it
yeah you want some you want some where's
my cotton want some cotton yay good and
everybody's happy because we have wine
again once more Britain has wine how
long does much rejoicing that's a lot of
mastic troops well I mean they're not
technologically advanced curious about
what the Aztecs are up to this is it
mine is mi they're invading a race in
Greece's land maybe they have open
bottles with them though oh we have data
mining that allows us to build people
ooh that sounds good yeah I guess we're
just being ok with Canterbury being
surrounded by our Tech's I mean you have
a lot of promise Hastings has finished
their research lab yeah oh I could build
a military AI lab yeah that gives you 30
experience for all units
you must have advanced AI to build it it
increases risk of rope superintelligence
by 2 per turn yes oh this is even worse
than a smart Defense Grid because now
we're talking about offensive
capabilities so this is the same there
is the kind of box that leaves the
allmovie deletes the military academy
that gives you extra experience so you
know how all of the indicators got one
improved one upgrade as we created them
yep it's because we started the modern
age so you have a box in all of your
cities right plus 30 means that you will
get added to upgrades just as you create
them yeah you know what this is like I
feel like there's all kinds of game
mechanics here that we're just not using
by virtue of being too good if you hide
too well and there are problems that
we're just not even facing like how
balance the necessary military benefit
that we need to survive with the area
swell day I risk mmm I'm very
uncomfortable about this hey the game of
chess is not merely an idle amusement
several very valuable qualities of the
mind useful in the course of human life
are to be acquired and strengthened by
it so as to become habits ready on all
occasions for life is a kind of chess
thanks Benjamin Franklin hmm he's on my
underwear actually I'm wearing Benjamin
Franklin underwear oh it's true that's
good to know
yeah it's a hundred dollar bill
underwear but hmm okay so this no means
that artists provide +1 n I research I
don't have any artists do I know there
are people who can be put in temples and
ah it's a temple actually didn't I okay
now we can build a data center it's the
future future
it became the future yeah Jonathan
Coulton was right okay so so they're you
with deep blue is that it captures
society's mind so it's not just AI
researchers that are now able to
contribute to this technological
progress
lots of other people can suddenly become
part of it right
it's becomes more of an
interdisciplinary thing yes almost a
social movement usually and in the midst
of all of this
oh hell apparently is breaking loose or
involve us debris I feel like it's gonna
ha
you all right hey he has changed his
facial expression yeah he looks a lot he
looks about the same angry it's just a
bit different this looks like a
different kind of angry now look
something I don't know he looks like you
just spilled his pint yeah this is
everybody looks very well your big [__]
and there is a unprotected general
outside London that the tank can just
steam all over
he never was very bright was he
Montezuma
I spent all this time building missile
cruises and tanks and things and didn't
get to use them and now I get to use
them bombers awaken
I feel bad for the house Tech's man I
feel embarrassed on their behalf
Iqbal was body nothing I'm cool I'm
gonna assume that he's the Star Wars guy
the fish one
come back with bomas is like very
effective but actually that fun
piss off Montezuma
I don't I don't I don't understand
Montezuma at all how much is this war
gonna have to cost him before he
realized this it's stupid
cool house takes a little just going on
but not something any jets I guess leads
on television
yeah and they're not gonna get vision
either cuz I'm gonna blow the crap out
of everything before it gets close he's
like yeah I'm annoyed I'm annoyed
because I'm trying to do a nice thing
here spending a lot of resources on air
safety research I'm trying to create
utopia and this guy who still has a
skull for a hat is coming at me with I
think it's just so those on his head
world war two he's got a golden skull on
him man
no yes yes this is very much a tricycle
whilst the will to fight yeah what would
it take no okay just it's very very
determined to be stupid and hurt himself
so I feel like AI safety-wise hmm this
has been relatively uneventful yeah
because no one else is gone what else is
going for that going for that wind
condition how are we doing we're still
more than double yeah so we actually can
be quite safe to just max out our AI
labs yeah I guess in this scenario it
turns out that alignment is not so hard
yes opening I will I'm in medieval yeah
yeah I mean I guess if you have if you
have full control of the project yeah
there's only one person working on it
and you haven't really kind of started
racing until you've discovered Northey
thesis and you've put a bunch of people
on the problem to begin with
yeah they could just come up with a
sensible solution that would be nice for
that'd be lovely yeah something is world
willing but kind of actually there are
worlds like that I've got atomic theory
yeah cool don't need it you're AI
researchers have reached the level of
expertise the new AI driven abundance
increases happiness in each city by to
meet that's good Wow we're doing really
well and it's just strange that we're at
war with it created what is that oh it's
uranium yeah it just became uranium yeah
we never cared about it before so we
didn't notice that the ground was gleich
that's exactly right
okay you know you only see things once
you know they're the other yeah no
that's true I do feel bad at talking
double-o do only breathing oh right in a
bridge in Dublin yeah we're gonna
liberate this out of Dublin ah
thank us in the future when you're no
longer a puppet
if ridiculous Dalton skull hat man I
feel bad though I do suicide is it such
a sadness your move Montezuma it's just
been nuked it must be so pissed yeah
fine idiot I can't get over how dummy is
your eye our research is one of the risk
of rogue superintelligence is becoming
higher consider dedicating more
resources to our safety to prevent
catastrophe well that's because we got
250 okay we're still about W I'm
comfortable with that
okay 602 now we are steadily advancing
we are extremely happy Wow Nikki
efficient fine
I'm more about fusion personally in this
beautiful oh it is fusion yeah I read
fission yeah yeah your vision for like
two years now
okay good you're discovering these
things one of you now that's pretty
crazy we heavily research oriented
civilization that is true
this is Britain we care about two things
AI research and bombers and those horse
guys so you're making so much research
now might just be the last time oh my
gosh look yeah do it what's happening on
I already promised it yeah no one else
is everyone okay fine ah well so it
turns out that's how you avoid an AI
race yes you have no one pursued other
than you yeah perfect
just make sure everyone's incredibly
militaristic I can start researching
future tech yeah you're done you done
with the research tree much left for the
AI to do for you yeah yeah I guess you
just became a tech speed speed down the
tech tree use that to gain follow up and
that you're going down the tech tree
yeah everyone else decided to go mean
turistica it backfired because we had
some priority yeah so uh good wouldn't
be so easy up because it passed 500 is
that yeah but we're nearly there
isn't it weird that
putting people in the Opera House is
better for AI research than putting them
in the university I mean have you seen
the kind of Whistler gets on your bills
like this no comment
coming in with tanks now yeah busy busy
anyway no concern of Falls no we're just
like double checking our code yeah you
have achieved victory through mastery of
science you have conquered the mysteries
of nature and ushered in a technology
that makes utopia Within Reach
your triumph will be remembered as long
as the stars burn in the night sky
hurrah
everything is wonderful and the Sun
never sets on an artificial intelligence
powered British Empire everything is
beautiful nothing hurts and also for the
best in this best of all possible worlds
[Music]
this video took a lot more editing work
than my usual videos in part because
it's a lot longer and also because I
started with about 9 hours of gameplay
footage I had to get some new equipment
to make it all work so I want to thank
my excellent patreon supporters all of
these people here for making it possible
in this video I'm especially thanking
Steve thank you Steve
I hope you enjoyed the little
behind-the-scenes video I made about how
this one was put together and I've also
uploaded the full like 8 hour long
version if you want to watch that anyway
thank you again and I'll see you next
time you think you can make anything
video